CRUMBLED SINCE, LAST PLACE IN
THE ATLANTIC DIVISION, LAST
PLACE IN THE EAST, TWO TEAMS
TRENDING IN OPP CANADIENS.
CARTER, DRIVES, STOPPED BY
HIM.
BURSTING
DOING HIS THING AGAIN.
>> Bob: WHAT I
SCORER.
INDIRECT THERE ON CHIAROT.
FRIEND THAT'S WHAT WE THOUGHT
THECK FROM THE CANADIANS,
PINBALLS AROUND, KAPANENA BOTH U
SKATE.
A CHIP.
WOW.
LOOK AT OUT BY
MR. POTASH.
>> Bob: THAT'S HIS AUDITION
TAME.
>> Ste
CANADA, IN.
CROSBY THE DRIVE OUT.
TAKE OFF THE ANGLE, CUTS IT POW.
ARE IT'S 2-0
AND THE CANADIENS'S GET IT RATE,
MIKE MARKET SON!
WHAT A SHIFT AND A LASER TO
WILL OF THAT
LOVE THE HAMMEL.
ROMANOV TO
OF HIS NETMINDER TRYO
THE BLAST FROM PAST.
THERE IT IS W.
SIZING IT UP.
BACK IF FRONT.
CROSBY IS ROBOB SKATE.
BLOCKER OF THE ALLEN.
GOT EN AWAY AT THE
KEEP HIMSELF EXCITED.
>> Bob: LOOK OUT 3.
>> Steve: JARRY WITH A BIG STOP
IN GOLD.
NOTHING HAPPENING THERE.
SUZUKI CAN'T GET IT OUT THOUGH.
GO UNNOTICED.
I WANT TO